a desculpem eu tinha que provar que
parou de tocar no meu batom porque eu
também tô a máquina de seus países
então é assim muito boa tarde a todos
antes de mais quero agradecer o convite
a oportunidade de estar aqui neste
inventário especial sinto muito
orgulhosa é um enorme prestígio
obrigada a ter apps é está a realizar se
na minha cidade a cidade que o viu
nascer a cidade com uma turma ou na
mulher que nunca diz nunca eu tenho 23
anos e desde pequeninas e bruxa e de
abraçar novos projectos sempre gostei de
ser dinâmica sempre dei o melhor de mim
sempre gostei de comunicar porque é isso
que eu são comunicativa
fui isso grata e ao longo da minha vida
foram muitos os desafios muito com deus
concretizei há pouco tempo sempre foi o
meu sonho eu sempre quero fazer a
diferença
quero ajudar alguém quero contribuir
para o bem estar não só meu mas as
pessoas que o rodeiam ipce cola
entreguei a minha tese na semana passada
pra mim foi um orgulho de minha vida foi
o sentimento da gratificação que jamais
consegue explicar não se explicar
não se vê não se ouve apenas 60 ao longo
da minha vida sempre sentir tudo sentir
as pessoas sentir os valores sentir os
princípios sempre fui uma pessoa cama e
dar valor a pequenas coisas
os gestos mais simples são os mais
intensos como ir à praia como estar
jantar com os amigos e com a família
mandar umas gargalhadas a rir a comédia
está em minha vida essa sou eu é cátia o
pedro diz khan
e nunca visto e nunca digo nunca é
verdade e consigam se o quarto os demais
projetos para o mp ficou lá embaixo da
área da l'oréal paris foi mais um
desafio proposto e claro que eu não
poderia dizer nunca porque eu entrego de
alma e coração porque aquilo que eu
acredito eu vou eu arrisco não importa
não vai lá
importa sim é o caminho é viagem
as pessoas que vamos conhecendo melhor
da vida pra mim é relação que nós temos
com as pessoas aqui vamos nós recebemos
é isso que nos enche o coração e é por
isso que eu sou muito fácil eu pratico
uma modalidade que chamava o vôo é como
sair no castelo da maia eu sou do braga
mas forman a universidade do porto e foi
que eu descobri a modalidade como se no
castelo da maia e fui contratada por
suporte em portugal que acreditou em mim
e disse que eu era capaz e fui não foi
fácil não mas eu acredito que o trabalho
persistência da violência e sobretudo o
meu vavá
nós conseguimos alcançar os nossos
objetivos quando eu fui contratada para
o sporting que estava no meu primeiro
ano de mestrado
o primeiro ano é muita sério de
especialização mas eu não desisto nunca
eu não deixei eu aceitei a proposta e
foi incansável
todas as semanas mais do que uma vez tem
aqui para lisboa mas eu ia aproveitava
as viagens do alfa pra proer para
resumir os artigos pra ir pra minha tese
é que eu consegui foi mais um desafio
superado e é o sentimento que eu acho é
nosso foi paciente está bem apesar da
minha vida ser refeita eo poeta dos
desafios
o maior desafio foi aos 13 anos
foi aí que a vida após a prova
o plantel e não diz nunca aos 13 anos
devido a uma doença rara e degenerativa
eu perdi a visão sim eu sou cega foi aos
13 anos que deixei de ver com os olhos e
passei a ver com o coração
foi aos 13 anos que das duas uma ou eu
parava por aí a minha vida eu continuava
a acreditar em mim
até aquela força coragem determinação
para que os meus objetivos sonhos sempre
mais permanecer intacto
e quer saber foi aos 13 anos khan onde a
curva e não via mas não contei a ninguém
continua a ir para a escola
é claro que as pessoas não estavam uma
mudança nos cargos no clero absurdas nos
olhos não consigo ver bem o caráter não
nos cash e hoje eu consigo vergonha
quando as unhas do caderno
as ligações eram de estar mais ao pé dos
meus amigos mas eu não tive coragem de
dizer khan aquilo que os médicos sempre
disseram que aquela menina um dia ia
ficar cega tenha chegado mas eu tenho
que realizar uma forma natural para
descontar
porque eu sou assim espontânea sempre
fui espalhafatosos e brincalhona e tenho
que arranjar uma forma mais difícil pra
mim era como é que eu vou contar os meus
pais principalmente a minha mãe um dia
passado uma semana e três dias deve ter
ficado cega
tanto é que eu fiquei cega ps foi uma
coisa que eu comer né
a certeza é porque eu tenho apanhado uma
briga séria no dia anterior estava
duplamente sério né
foi isso que eu tenho que fazer o
trabalho de casa
nunca mais vou esquecer é conjugar o
verbo é na disciplina de português
a minha mais copa nem me perguntam cada
dia que passa todas as projeto torto
eu respondo ele comanda naturalidade
possível
amanhã já não vejo e foi o início da
minha vida fui que fiquem sem visão
mas foi aqui que eu dei cor a minha vida
foi que eu percebi bom esse foi o
conhecimento mas isso não é nenhuma 300
milhões é virar por uma prova eu vou
desistir nós da fifa não cola entre
popular primeiros em direito na
universidade do minho eu testei eu
estava cega na que o curso
sinceramente eu cheguei a casa vi isso
na minha mãe é mãe
olha eu vou propor toxicologia e ela é
toda a certeza não quer ficar em braga
na etapa que eu disse não eu vou e fui
foi o porte não conhecer nada nem
conhecia ninguém como costumo dizer fui
pra aumentar às cegas né
mas foi por causa que nós temos que
voarem bardot construindo nosso próprio
caminho
os meus amigos e minha família são os
dois pilares cederam as asas e o vôo e
vôo e vôo alto porque acredito porque
quero porque consigo não é só fruto da
minha determinação da minha força
vontade não é porque eu tenho o amor o
carinho dos meus amigos e da minha
família eu acredito
e eu digo mesmo eu com a minha cabeça
levantada sorriso no rosto coberto no
rosto em bengala na mão eu vou não quero
e vou e não tenho medo porque a vida é
assim e nunca desisti de nada por ser
cega por contrário à cegueira
vilma mais coragem e acima tudo ser cega
época é uma oportunidade quando eu
estava no sport ilha permanece em um dos
muitos tribunais internacionais ficam
viradas para jogar em madri
eu fui sozinha
os meus amigos ea minha mãe
perguntávamos sempre
a eucaristia foi sozinha tudo que nós
vamos continuar e não sair das aulas nem
estava no primeiro ano está a sair das
aulas fiz a mala chegar em casa e fez a
mala apanhei dois metros o avião acho
que madri jogar embora eu vou quando
recebi a proposta da l'oréal paris é é
outro grande projeto k que eu me sinto
muito lisonjeada porque sou a primeira
pessoa com deficiência que não é a minha
seleção é problema seu deixar que seja
uma pessoa em frente mas não somos todos
ea sinto muito feliz por ser a primeira
pessoa a trabalhar porque apesar de não
vieram os outros times não é o que foi
tratado em mim eu sempre gostei de
imagem e l'oréal achou incrível como é
que eu não via uma aqueles sozinha
recebeu com festa e tal quer dizer que
não precisa espelho e não eu aprendi e
mais uma vez foi um grande desafio e eu
nunca disse que nunca nem nunca irá
brevemente será uma nova campanha daqui
a uns dias e como ele está um pouco é
uma campanha que vai fazer a diferença e
fico muito feliz com o coração aí não é
nada melhor que isso é porque o facto
quando nós damos o nosso melhor como até
champô resto vem por acréscimo em
catadupa é mesmo assim é mas para que o
conselho estatal e não disse que era
porque eu não sou cega é cega que o que
não quer ver é só não faz com os olhos e
é tudo natural
os meus amigos kessy a minha mãe com
vínculo com as 24 anos e continuo a
achar a casa da nota estão a criar as
curas tudo vai pelos apagar a continuar
imaginem a contextos mutirão judiaria
nós vamos um bar uma discoteca e eu sei
que eu aprendi que sou cega porque eu
também não quero enfatizar isso eu sou
normal
completamente normal ainda por cima o
quarentão maquiar e e assim de salto
alto é que ninguém nota não pode ser ela
via e ó advogado mas só tem as lâmpadas
fundidas na é ótimo é muito engraçado
porque as pessoas não notam e quase se
percebem ficam é embarcada seu espaço
uma filha e os meus amigos
imagine o que entrar numa discoteca é os
porteiros pensão e que o papel é
respeitada e não pague um papel é curtir
a noite todas as minhas amigas é eu
esqueci porque eu sou a kátia eu não sou
a mulher segue a sua kátia eu trabalhei
no colégio de gaia com psicóloga
estagiária e aquilo que eu disse foi eu
não admito que me tratem de outra forma
por ser sincera eu sou kaká tissot
psicóloga e sou competente e pra mim
esse é o melhor
ainda bem que as pessoas esquecem que eu
não vejo minhas amigas tiram fotos
aviação delas é aí o caso da cirurgia
mostram a sério é respeito engraçado é
muito tiro aconteceu uma situação há
pouco tempo no rival fitch que que essa
é foi que processaria mente porque eu
fui à casa de banho com as minhas amigas
e eu estava tocar o button estava aqui é
o cadu e por acaso fez ótima surpresa
shopping mesmo assim ai q crível está
maquiar dois já estavam nos sentir hoje
o profissional porque ela não teria
percebido que ela anseia as fitas estão
engraçadas que acontece no dia a dia com
a minha forma de de hoje a atitude a
atitude é que o que faz toda a diferença
muitas vezes eu vou na rua e não conhece
bem o caminho não é esse o pantanal eu
sinto a lei antes que o pentágono olha
eu quero ir pra subir as escadas ruas
sábado a equipe cima e também
classificadas como ótimas cenas de
esquerda ou de direita e só está é pra
minha mulher eu pois mas não nua quanto
porque este movimento e seus produtos
após apanhar e eu não
não vais o senhora a fazer é é acontece
três porque total natural e é tão bom
assim é tão bom assim
estou tão fui eu mesmo e eu sinto muito
esvaziada há pouco tempo fui a fazer uma
viagem com uma amiga minha
é eu e minha amiga é comentou com outros
amigos que de viagem com batatinha else
praí kate é aquela sua amiga que não via
ele faz viajar com ela eu não tinha
percebido o aumento viajar com um com
como a kate após a carta não vê porque
eu sou a kátia é é tão normal e nesta
viagem tem por que eu pudesse fotografar
o que me pega eu tirei fotos eu fiz tudo
pra eu sou muito vivida e entra bem mais
ao sol porque tem os melhores comigo
sem dúvida que são muitos pois é que vou
continuar
saiu porque é porque o essencial é
invisível aos olhos
há pouco tempo eu descobri meu é meu
amigo há cinco anos que eu era negro
como se isso fosse importante descobrir
uma conversa no bar em que se virou para
mim e disse ah eu sou negão mais directo
conhece eu
espera lá foi que eu tava na tabela
porque meus amigos sempre natália comigo
e eu com eles não é tanto é que costumam
andrés quando as coisas na minha escolha
das chaves do carro são loucos a procura
é é viver nos furtamos muito da vira e
ouvir esta série 3 mesmo negra
eu sei só para saber se eu nunca saber
se os negros pretos e olhos azuis
vermelhos amarelos não sair e só depois
um monge está sempre presente na minha
vida e tenho o costume de brincar como
já puderam verificar vira pra eles
ol e os é gato preto com a escuridão
ainda bem que eu não tenho medo dos cor
ou é é minha e sim estamos
permanentemente a brincar com os meus
amigos são daquelas que vamos um café
esquece isso às vezes nenhuma eu esquece
não dar a mão porque somos assim porque
é cátia não sou a mulher cega e isto é é
o melhor que eu posso ser ainda ouvia
eu tenho uma irmã pequenina e diz que
ela nasceu sempre tomar conta dela e
para muita gente isso é muito estranho
mas não é
é mais um desafio eu olho do comer eu
visto pra quem não conhece é muito
estranho mas não é tudo muito natural
mas também às vezes é a sociedade acha
estranho porque não conhece é porque
nunca conviveu com uma pessoa assim e é
normal é perfeitamente compreensível mas
apesar da minha vida se a completa do
desafios
eu sei que o melhor ainda está para vir
e vos garanto eu nunca digo nunca
[Aplausos]
tudo aquilo criança tudo aquilo que eu
queria conquistar permaneceu que eu sei
que eu sou sei o valor que tem e sei que
tem capacidade e vontade para fazer tudo
aquilo que eu quero com uma boa atitude
é super positiva uma nova forma de estar
descontraída nós conseguimos transmitir
confiança não só para nós próprios mas
também para os outros e eu tenho o
objetivo de me tornar melhor jogadora do
uol
a língua nacional bem como tornar numa
referência a nível internacional
a determinação é o tom foi na minha
história
[Música]
[Aplausos]